it's early morning in the nakuru
national park in Kenya and a team of
gamekeepers and biologists has
tranquilized a rhinoceros they have 10
minutes until the animal wakes up again
in the meantime the Rhinos enormous body
has to be kept cooled with water they
take its measurements and a blood sample
and also remove a tiny piece of one year
we have a tissue wouldn't have a lot of
them you will help the hair samples from
dating so you do but with a cup the
samples are sent to a laboratory in the
capital Nairobi their researchers
analyzed the animals DNA and record the
results in a special database or rhinos
and elephants so you get a variety of
something like avoid this kind of ivory
data we kept them from the base of the
of the Han this case is one handle
ivorian you can see this is a very
process they have been cut into chips
because this is very hard for you to
know that this is ivory when poachers
are caught with a piece of ivory or
rhino horn the researchers can then use
the computer records to determine which
animal it was taken from the team in
Kenya cooperate closely with their
counterparts in South Africa who first
developed the database yesterday we
received seven hands here from a guy who
was arrested yankin from was a beak so
those samples you are going to take to
link get their profiles and then link
them with our database it's the only way
the team can prove that the horn in
question has been illegally acquired but
high demand and soaring prices on the
black market mean that poaching
continues to grow most of the horns end
up in asia that's where genetic engineer
george bone AC and his partner Matthew
Marcus come in in their laboratory in
San Francisco on the west coast of the
US they are manufacturing artificial
rhino horn the aim is to flood the
market with
they're cut-price version black market
price right now there's ranges from 30
thousand dollars per kilogram to up to a
hundred thousand dollars per kilogram
we're start targeting a seven thousand
dollar per kilogram figure and we think
that that is going to be a good price
point that will put a lot of pressure on
the poachers in the poaching syndicates
because it'll be harder for them to make
money to bribe officials and to do other
things the artificial horn largely
consists of rhino keratin made with
biotechnological methods the bio
engineers also a dry no DNA with the
help of a 3d printer the resulting
powder is then transformed into a
full-size solid horn because of the
manufacturing process the result doesn't
just look like a rhino horn the
researchers say it's genetically
identical they show us a prototype we're
going to be looking at shark fin which
is obviously very popular in China
Pangolin scales which are also made of
keratin tiger bone which is also used in
traditional Chinese medicine ivory which
obviously has a lot of history in the
West for use and durable good products
so all kinds of anything that where an
animal is used in a tradition we want to
be able to remove that animal from the
goods chain opinion is divided on
whether the artificial horn will
actually put poachers out of business
but with the rhino population in Kenya
now down to just a thousand animals they
need all the help they can get
you